right so as you saw as you see right
there gas is expensive right now price
is at an all-time high well this morning
the biggest golden knights and smiths
are going to try and ease your burden
vgk foundation vg key alumni association
and smith's they are giving away 50
of gas for free
but it's to the first eight hundred cars
mary jane belly isn't joining us live at
that smith's location mary jane you met
somebody who had been up since 2 30
there waiting in line
yeah absolutely heather and john you
know i wish i should have brought my car
because free gas 50 to fill up your tank
really goes a long way and one of those
drivers joining me today is greg garcia
he came in early at 2 30 a.m and greg
you know this isn't the first time that
you came to an event like this you were
at the last one too it was definitely uh
the way gas prices are times are tough
so every little bit helps and certainly
free gas that's a that's a lot that
helps a whole lot for my family and
we're talking about 50 in free gas i
mean that really goes to
bills or something else like food that
could really help out exactly right i
mean
everything is so expensive now because
gas prices are high
just having a budget is very difficult
so that extra fifty dollars means we
could go out watch some movies or do a
lot of fun time with the family so it
definitely helps a lot we definitely
appreciate vgk and smith's for giving
this
to us give you know giving back to the
community it helps a lot
well greg i mean just like many others i
know you've been here so early trying to
take a nap probably as well as many
other people here and greg is one of the
first 800 people here getting free gas
even if you don't come today at this
location gas will be about
16 cents cheaper through today and
tomorrow so make sure you come in and
take advantage of this it starts at 8 00
am as the pumps open again many people
are here as early as 2 30 a.m we're
talking about 40 000 dollars of fuel 50
dollars for the first 800 cars we'll be
here all morning reporting live from
smith's mary jane ballista live local
now